I'm super fashion woman Hayden we know
you're a busy woman so we'll make this
quick but we're just dying to know if
you're currently seeing someone or
focusing on your goals like you
previously mentioned you've got a few
new movies coming out soon and your
future co-stars are totally boyfriend
material so we'll wait and see if any
sparks fly you would tell us the truth
wouldn't you I'm in love with you
there's no doubt about it
Peyton list is downright amazing so
we're not too surprised that she's
broken a few hearts along the way you
won't believe which one of Peyton's
ex-boyfriends was kicked out of the
Disney Channel family for breaking all
the rules watch until the end to find
out who we're talking about Cameron
Monaghan Peyton lists has been a busy
lady ever since she chose to leave her
Disney Channel days behind one of her
first gigs outside of the Disney realm
was the one of faith and anthem of a
teenage prophet and it's here that she
met her ex-boyfriend Cameron Monaghan
the actors got to know each other while
filming the movie and instantly hit it
off for those of you who don't know
Cameron is a terrific actor who's known
for playing Jeremy on Gotham and Ian
Gallagher on shameless the couple
decided to call it quits over the
holidays in 2019 they made their
relationship Instagram official in
September 2017 when they shared some
truly adorable Disneyland pictures
Peyton's fans first heard about the
split from enews but the breakup was
officially announced by Cameron himself
via Twitter it was here that he
confirmed the breakup while sending
Peyton some very kind words he thanked
her for sharing nearly two years of her
life with him and wished her the best
now that's what we call him mature and
friendly celebrity breakup the next
ex-boyfriend on this list was never
exactly confirmed but there were once
some serious rumors circulating around
stating otherwise we're talking about
Peyton's secret relationship with her
former Diary of a Wimpy Kid co-star call
me Zachary Gordon Peyton and Zachary are
two Disney Channel stars who managed to
hit it off back in 2009 when they were
just preteens they were rumoured to be
dating from February 2009 to May 2010
right before being cast as
Diary of a Wimpy Kid co-stars Payton and
Zack were matched up together on screen
while filming
rodrick Rules and dog days although they
never made it a point to official eyes
their relationship the couple posted
many convincing pictures to their social
media accounts however since these two
Disney Channel stars were under contract
they never really talked about their
relationship which is why it's said to
have been nothing but a rumor Zachary
was arguably one of Peyton's first loves
after all they were just 13 years old
when they dated for about a year but if
you really think about it Peyton's first
real love was none other than the late
great Cameron Boyce Cameron Boyce Peyton
and Karen were Disney Channel stars who
grew up together and quickly formed a
bond the ex-lovers started dating in
November 2012 and called it quits in
April 2015
despite dating for two and a half years
Payton and Cameron remained good friends
who loved and supported each other they
met on the set of Jessie in 2011 and
swiftly came together in their teenage
years however many sources have stated
that Payton camera's relationship was
nothing more than friendly but Aiden's
diehard fans beg to differ whether they
were truly an item or not it's clear
that the co-stars shared a very deep
bond the world is still in shock over
Cameron's tragic passing Peyton included
the Disney actress posted a touching
tribute about her dear old friend and
possible lover stating that she would
never stop talking about him and wished
she could hug him one more time
it's easy to see that Cameron was the
best boyfriend Peyton could ever have
asked for oh that makes it less
offensive not crying Jake at Bertrand's
next up on Peyton's list is Jacob
Bertrand a Disney Channel star who was
rumored to have dated Peyton back in
2016 the couple met on the set of the
Disney Channel Original Movie the swap
but sparks didn't fly between them for
too long in fact their relationship is
said to have lasted all but three months
funny enough Peyton and Jacobs paths
would cross again in 2019 when both
actors appeared on the TV series Cobra
Kai however the former lovers didn't
rekindle their relationship like some of
their fans would have hoped
both Jacob and Peyton have moved on from
the Disney Channel and set their sights
on bigger and better things and who
knows maybe they'll meet again on a
different set in the future and fall for
each other
all over again so if you've made it this
far you're probably dying to know about
Peyton's ex-boyfriend you know the one
who got kicked off the Disney Channel
Logan Paul Peyton and Logan's
relationship was short-lived and there's
much debate on whether it happened or
not but the former Disney stars were
rumored to have hit it off for a few
months starting in October 2016 the
YouTube sensation and former Brizard
bark actor was kicked out of the Disney
Channel family in the summer of 2017
after an incidents when an L a news crew
was made public regardless of their
rumored fling Kate and Logan have
continued to act side by side you can
catch them sharing the screen in 28
teens the thinning new world order and
the upcoming movie valley girl so which
one of Peyton's ex-boyfriends is your
favorite and why ours will forever be
the angel that is Cameron voice no
explanation needed for more videos about
your favorite Disney stars and
celebrities subscribe to the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll
catch you later
[Music]